That's sick, I can literally
watch that all day.
Yeah I know, it was awesome.
Hello there and welcome to this extremely
scientific episode of The Slow Mo Guys.
We're in a lab.
Yeah for once right.
For once our lab coats makes sense.
Yeah.
GE actually flew us all the
way to New York to their labs
which is awesome.
Holiday and everything.
Yeah. They want us to film a
bunch of their technologies.
So we're going to start with this video.
We've also done two more
videos on GE's channel.
So be sure to check those
out, che-che-check those out.
Yeah.
So this video, we've got some
super hydrophobic material.
It's manmade, it acts
similar to a lotus leaf.
So if you want to squirt
some water in there,
it shows see.
So as water it runs off.
Yeah. And that is hydrophobic material.
This one here is manmade.
And we're going to test that
with some food coloring water
and get that slow mo. See how it looks.
The way it works in nature
is that there's actually
tiny nanoscopic hairs
on the plant, Which trap a layer of air,
and that causes the water just
not to be able to penetrate.
Basically, spits off the
air that are trapped.
And this is the manmade version.
So we're going to take the Phantom.
And we're going to take a macro lens
get some super close up
shots of the way water reacts
on a super hydrophobic surface.
Science.
A minute, I'm just pouring
out some food coloring
into this container here.
I'm going to pour it onto the
surface all at the same time.
And hopefully.
Get a nice collision yeah.
Get nice collision sort of
splooshing, if you like.
It's a good word.
That is the technical term.
Yeah, I believe so.
So we've got red and blue.
Red and blue.
Hopefully, it will merge and
we'll get some cool shots.
How much do you want done?
Let's just first do it all.
3-2-1.
Boom.
I've honestly, I've seen robots
with worse timing than that.
That's ridiculous.
Literally perfect.
Like how it sort of just
looks like a flower.
It spreads out completely.
And then just bounces off.
It's so weird.
It's really cool.
All right, so now we're
gonna try that again,
but backlight it so you
can see through the liquid.
3-2-1.
So another thing that happens is
that ion filings in water.
When the magnet goes up to them,
it's very easy to
differentiate the ion filings
from the liquid.
If the iron filings have been shaved
down to a nanoscopic scale,
you basically get metallic liquid.
Like Terminator 2 basically.
It looks like it looks like the T-1000.
It is so cool.
Okay. So here is the Ferris liquid.
So it's got the nano sized ion filings
ion particles in there
and this is a magnet.
Going to place the magnet
down the test tube like this
and then lift up the
liquid towards the magnet
and watch as it gets attracted
See how in dense before
you like pushes down and then shoots up
and you end up with
basically a magnetic ball.
That is really cool.
So good.
And that's even sort of
traps to other bits metal as well.
So you can see how that works there.
And keep the plate angled slightly
towards the camera all the way.
Okay, ready?
Yeah.
Alright, it's good.
I just loved the way that it.
I'm sorry.
There's no need for that.
Sorry.
This was literally brand new.
That's literally been in use
for about thirty minutes.
Well, I hope you enjoyed that video.
Can't go wrong with liquids,
they always look good.
So be sure to follow us on Twitter,
and also check out the two videos
we made for GE's channel.
One is called MEMS
and the other is called cold spray.
And if you're intrigued by
them, give them a click,
give them a watch.
Guess we've got to get
escorted out of here.
Yeah, armed guards and everything.
How can they not trust us?
I don't know.